[Musik]
zum nikolaus bereiten eine kleine
überraschung eine physikalische
überraschung wir machen eiskonfekt das
macht nämlich ordentlich kalt im mund
und da ist auf rein physikalischem weg
dazu brauchen wir
dunkle schokolade kokosfett wir werden
das ganze unterstützen durch der
nikolaus kommt aus dem wald durch weit
sogar die rote bete zu gott
wir haben hier ein spezialgerät riedrode
das ist ein zuger alkohol nicht weniger
süß aber dafür macht er noch mal fühlen
und also wir haben hier ein richtig
schönes dessert schokolade erhitzen sich
am besten im wasserbad ich gebe deshalb
die schokolade hier in dieser misslichen
und wir wissen ja schokolade halten
bestimmten schmelzpunkt so das ist die
mund schmilzt wir wollen den
schmelzpunkt senken und schmelzpunkt
senken kann man zum beispiel mit einem
anderen fed das ist in diesem fall
kokosfett und dann gibt man ungefähr
schokolade und kokosfett etwa eins zu
eins dazu
das klingt jetzt viel aber wir wollen
eben diese nikolaus überraschungs
verkühlen veranstalten
das ist wirklich eine überraschung zu
wehren dass milch gebe hier zur
aromatisierung noch etwas reißen will
dazu dass du ein
zweibrücken die sind sehr intensiv
kriegt ich fantastisch und rühren dass
ein verein den tönen effekt des
eiskonfekt kennt man ja das kühlt auf
der zunge ziemlich rasch aus wir haben
dennoch ein bisschen verstärkt in dem ja
etwas aussetzen lassen wir aus der
physik erkennen und schokolade hatten
bestimmen schmelzpunkt hier tragen wir
die temperatur auf von ungefähr so 33
grad kokosfett hat ja etwas niedrigen
von um die 28 grad
wenn wir beide aber mischen dann
entsteht nicht eine verbindung die
ebenso aussieht eine lineare lineare
abfall sollen wir bekommen hier etwas
völlig neues wenn wir hier beginnt der
schmelzpunkt relativ stark abzusinken
und hier mit dem stark einzusteigen das
heißt wir haben hier eine viel
schnellere kühlung als man das hier
erwarten würde bei der linearen mischung
und das hat man hier ein ideales
architekt ito
das heißt also wir haben uns also
hingegen von hergeschoben bei 50 prozent
also 50 50 mischung von schokolade und
kokosfett haben hier einen schmelzpunkt
dpa kein bereich wer hat wo meine fis
flüssige und feste phase hat sondern es
geht sofort in die beste phase und von
der festen phase sofort eingestellt
das geht so rasch dass unsere
blutzirkulation nicht nachkommt mit dem
erbarmen mit der warme zuvor deswegen
empfinden wir das als extrem für die
schokolade und kokosnuss geschmolzen und
es beginne ich das hier vorsichtig
einzugießen möglichst kleinen silikon
als bereiter weil dann bekommt man zwar
wieder unfallfrei raus wenn das der
stadt ist das muss nun abkühlen nach und
nach unterkühlt an keiner stelle mit
einer besseren kühlschrank so bleibt sie
eigentlich dann wenn man sich langsam
abkühlt schön kommen während das eis
konfekt jetzt kühlt bereiten wir unsere
zucker zu ich beginne mit dem rote beete
zucker dann hat man einfach ein bisschen
wasser
sogar das rote beete pulver das bekommt
man eben naturkostladen mittlerweile und
kochen das einfach zu einem sierung
[Musik]
das einfach backpapier austrocknen
dann ein bisschen nach druck im beruf
oder halt man solche großprojekte chips
weil ich das mal breche dann sieht man
dass bricht also wunderbar durch und
gibt dann auch im bund so ein richtig
schönes knuspriges gefühl und genau
darauf kommt es mir an
zum einen schöne weihnachtsfeier zum
anderen eben gleichzeitig zum schmelzen
überraschenderweise auch etwas klos
tricks für den wald zucker nehmen wir
kräuter die den wald symbolisieren
astori mal zucker dann gebe ich hier
einfach in diesem mixa dann gebe ich
einfach von den rosmarin dass es kann
natürlich auch themen sein das kann
natürlich nach weihnachten die
tannenzweige seiten die nadeln steckt
auch sehr gut wichtig ist beim rosmarin
das eben vorwiegend die pferde drin sind
weil die studie sehr bitter werden und
dann bei der - nicht so kritisch da
können die steine mit verwendet werden
da ein bisschen weniger dazu sonst
dominiert die nachher mit ihrem
geschmack in aromen und gang deckel
drauf und dann vollgas
[Musik]
so das könnte man noch ein zweimal mixen
kapazität hier ist es eigentlich ein
zucker der noch ein bisschen feucht ist
natürlich durch die feuchtigkeit der
kräuter das legt man auf backpapier aus
und danach nach dem trocknen sieht das
so aus und ist relativ trocken in den
händen da macht man sich eine größere
menge davon und dann stellt man das
luftdicht abgeschlossen in der box und
dann hat man länger seite von
[Musik]
das war richtig schön kühl